veamos si podemos averiguar cuánto es x
+ 7 al cuadrado y te recomiendo que le
pongas una pausa del vídeo y lo intentes
por tu cuenta
bueno ahora lo vamos a resolver juntos
aquí cuando tenemos x 7 al cuadrado hay
que recordar que estamos elevando al
cuadrado todo esto de aquí no quiere
entonces lo que tenemos es x más 7 x y
voy a escribir el otro x 7 de otro color
x + 7 porque eso va a ser muy útil
cuando realmente estamos multiplicando
estos dos paréntesis ahora ya que los
tenemos así podemos simplemente
multiplicarlos como si estuviéramos
multiplicando cualesquiera dos binomios
y primero voy a hacer esta
multiplicación de la forma sencilla
aunque sea un poco más lenta utilizando
dos veces la propiedad distributiva y
después podemos ponernos a pensar en
algunos patrones que surgen sobre todo
cuando tenemos un binomio al cuadrado
ahora empecemos aplicando la propiedad
distributiva dos veces primero vamos a
distribuir el x7 amarillo
el x7 rosa ok entonces tenemos x rosa x
x 7 amarillo x + 7 + 7 rosa más 7 rosa x
x + 7 y ahora pues tenemos que volver a
aplicar la propiedad distributiva
podemos tomar este x rosa y distribuirlo
en este x 7 y nos queda x x x x al
cuadrado más x x 7 que es 7x y ahora lo
tenemos que hacer por acá también 67 x x
es otro 7x y 7 por 7 es 49 y ya estamos
en la recta final ya nada más tenemos
que simplificar esto de aquí que ahí
tenemos x al cuadrado más pero por aquí
estos dos términos de primer grado se
suman
nos queda 14 x y luego tenemos más 49 y
ya terminamos ahora la pregunta que nos
tenemos que hacer aquí es si vemos
alguna especie de patrón por acá ok si
vemos algún patrón que podamos
generalizar y que nos ayuden a elevar
binomios al cuadrado de una forma más
rápida y fácil podemos recordar que
cuando vimos la multiplicación de
binomios encontramos un patrón muy
interesante y ese patrón nos decía que
si tenemos por ejemplo x + a por x + b
no creáis donde en estos dos binomios el
coeficiente de la x es un 1 vimos que
esta multiplicación va a ser igual a x
al cuadrado más
a más b por equis más a por ver ahora si
a y b son exactamente iguales o sea si
tenemos x más a por x más a entonces
podemos decir que esto es igual a x al
cuadrado x al cuadrado más a más otra a
por x ok a más a por x más y aquí esta
vez es otra y entonces nos queda a por a
y esto de aquí es igual a x al cuadrado
más a massa es 2a x
más ahora es al cuadrado
y bueno esta es la forma desarrollada de
expresar un binomio al cuadrado bueno
más bien un binomio en el que el
coeficiente de la x sea 1 y además esto
es exactamente lo mismo que obtuvimos
por aquí en este ejemplo el 7 es la a y
entonces tenemos x al cuadrado este x al
cuadrado azul de aquí que deja melo
círculo por acá corresponde con este y
luego tendríamos más 2
x pero la a es un 7
entonces 2 por 7 es 14 tendríamos 14 x y
xi tenemos hace 14 x por aquí así es que
este 14 x en naranja corresponde al 2 a
x y finalmente como a es 7 a al cuadrado
que es 49 y entonces cuando estemos
haciendo binomios al cuadrado una forma
muy fácil es simplemente utilizar este
patrón de aquí
y podemos hacer otro ejercicio
rápidamente para asegurarnos de que
entendimos muchas cosas porque podemos
poner por aquí x menos 3 y aquí estamos
poniendo un signo negativo pero bueno x
menos 3 al cuadrado y te recomiendo que
intentes encontrar este binomio al
cuadrado
utilizando este patrón de aquí ok por la
pausa inténtalo
bueno pues x menos 3 al cuadrado va a
ser igual por aquí menos 3 es nuestra y
porque ya hay que tener mucho cuidado en
que es menos 3 y este binomio al
cuadrado según nuestro patrón va a ser
igual a x al cuadrado que x al cuadrado
más 2 a x pero cuánto es 2a
es menos 3 entonces 2a es 2 x menos 3 o
sea menos 6 aunque entonces tenemos aquí
menos
x2 x a es menos 6
este es nuestro coeficiente y luego nada
más tenemos que poner una equis y
finalmente más a al cuadrado ahora sí ya
es menos 3 cuanto es a al cuadrado pues
menos 3 al cuadrado es 9 gray más 9 y
así de fácil
utilizando este patrón que tenemos por
aquí encontramos súper rápido cuál es
este binomio al cuadrado ahora si
quisieras también podrías hacer todo
este desarrollo utilizando la propiedad
distributiva dos veces y verificar que
esto de aquí en efecto es x menos 3 al
cuadrado